30 minuten lang hatte markus söder
gerade mit uns gesprochen und es war
wirklich ein spannendes interview es hat
vor allem gezeigt wie man als
kanzlerkandidat auftreten könnte wenn
man einer wer bei uns weiter in dem
studio julian reichelt er das interview
geführt hat und claus strunz das beste
war natürlich ganz zum schluss auf die
frage wird armin laschet der nächste
kanzler sein da kam klar aber das
eigentlich entscheidende war das gesicht
dabei das eigentlich entscheidende war
das gesicht wir werden das unseren
zuschauern hier in kürzester zeit
präsentieren wollen klaus hat gerade
gesagt dass ungefähr so alt wird man
sagen wird arminia bielefeld deutscher
meister man sagt klar
man hatte das gefühl
markus söder versucht geradezu durch
vorleben
armin laschet in den kampfgeist zu
zwingen den er da selber ausstrahlt du
hast gerade gesagt thomas so könnte man
als kanzlerkandidat auftritten bisher
tut die union das nicht die werte
sprechen da für sich und man hat das
gefühl markus söder versucht verzweifelt
diesen geist zu entfachen bei der union
allein so richtig gelingen würde sie
bisher nicht
ist auch so wahrgenommen diese muss man
ja weiter sagen ist schon dass microsoft
gar nicht sagen muss ich wäre der
bessere sondern dass das quasi die
unterzeile unter dem ganzen den ganzen
interviews es gibt gerne eine alte ganz
einfache regel also wenn immer
sonnenschein ist dann kann es da eine
machen oder dann aber wem vertraut man
dass er dich aus einer krise führen
würde wenn ein haus brennt ja und alle
müssen schnell raus und man weiß aber
nicht genau wo der richtige weg ist
folge ich dann lieber armin laschet der
sagt dann muss ich mich um einen
arbeitskreis einberufen und in nordrhein
westfalen haben wir das damals so
gemacht oder folge ich dann lieber
markus söder der sagt ich habe mir den
weg gemerkt den notausgang wir gehen
jetzt da lang da lang und da lang und
ich glaube dass sich das vermittelt
nicht sozusagen der blick nach oben an
einen anführer aber das pragmatische wir
tun jetzt was und wir setzen uns auch
ein ziel er hat ja auch klar definiert
ziel dieses wahlkampfs muss jetzt sein
klar zu machen was eine linksregierung
für deutschland bedeuten würde nämlich
wirtschaftlichen niedergang
internationale isolierung ja doch
schröder und lafontaine verwiesen dass
ein wichtiger historischer verweis ist
begann schlecht ist von schröder dann
korrigiert worden wer übrigens von von
söder den zweiten teil mit zu erzählen
aber darum geht dass man muss ja auch
mal sagen das sind meine gegner herrscht
sie sind mein gegner im wahlkampf könnte
zum beispiel laschet am sonntag im trial
sagen herr scholz das meiste was sie
vorhaben ist schlecht für unser land und
ich sage ihnen mal wie es richtig geht
ja oder hier sind meine idee und das
alles steckt aber in armin laschet nicht
deshalb ist dieser aufruf zum kampf so
als würde man ein federball ein
federball deutschen meister irgendwie
die fußball-bundesliga schicken das wird
kein richtiger stürmer mehr sie haben
markus söder auch nochmal gefragt wäre
er denn bereit wenn jemand zu ihm käme
und fragen würde und er sagt ganz klar
da kommt keiner mehr und fragen man
spürt das ist ehrlich gesagt ist glaubt
ja ich halte das auch für für nicht die
ganze weit dass da keiner mehr fragt
zwei interessante punkte an zwei punkten
hat er nämlich sich klar gegen armin
laschet gestellt erstens bei einem punkt
der so viele menschen in diesem land
ganz direkt betrifft benzinpreis an die
scheuer hierbei bild live vor zwei tagen
gesagt bei zwei euro das versprechen
benzinpreis bremse muss schluss sein
über zwei euro darf sich geht am
liebsten camila stadt gefragt was hält
er davon wusste er nicht genau was er
dazu sagen sollte gesagt erhält die
marke von zwei euro für aus der luft
gegriffen er es war auf jeden fall nicht
klar hier markus söder vollkommen klar
bei zwei euro findet der entspannenden
gedanken muss schluss sein zweiter punkt
auch hochinteressant er hat gerade das
traum wahlergebnis das ziel wahlergebnis
von armin laschet für beerdigt erklärt
armin laschet auch hierbei bild live hat
gesagt 30 prozent sind noch drin damals
stand a22 nehmen muss man sagen damals
stand aber 22 dass die augen als ein
weiter weg bis zu erreichen jetzt steht
aber 19 weg ist noch weiter geworden
markus söder hat gesagt von 19 auf 30
hält er nicht mehr für realistisch dann
doch ja klar da ist es wieder es waren
schon man muss sagen das waren schon
doch auch dramatische eingeständnisse
was die ziele angeht er hat gesagt wir
wollen vor der spd landen was ein ziel
hat selber dazu gesagt hätte er sich
auch nicht gedacht dass er das vor ein
paar monaten dass er das mal ausgeben
würde und die einzige realistische
option oder wahrscheinlichste option für
die cdu ist eine jamaika-koalition
ja also da wird schon deutlich runter
einmal
kleine brötchen gebacken ganz genau er
hat aber in so einem nebensatz auch noch
was anderes interessantes gesagt er hat
gesagt dass man sich von gedanken
verabschieden sollte in der union in die
juniorpartnerschaft als kleinerer
partner zum beispiel dann eine große
koalition einzutreten also auch da
scheint es irgendwie gedankenspiele
zugegeben etwas was markus söder dort er
vermutet denn er hat ganz klar gesagt
wir müssen vor die spd und hat
denjenigen die da offenbar vielleicht
plant sein naja vizekanzler war ja auch
ganz schön außenminister ganz klar
gesagt das geht hier nicht hier muss
gekämpft werden und wir müssen vor der
spd und ich will noch einmal auf dieses
wichtige abgrenzen beim benzinpreis zu
sprechen kommen denn da geht es ja
sozusagen sachlich um den benzinpreis
und ich finde es schon bemerkenswert ist
ein unions kanzlerkandidat dann nicht
eine klare linie 1 sieht es aber sein ja
wie gesagt nur unterstützer seien gut
verdaut so weit ich gehen ganz klar tut
interview
es geht aber ja dabei vor allem auch
darum dass man bei armin laschet den
puls fühlen kann das ja schon punkte
nicht scharf formuliert die am schluss
mit den grünen kompatibel machen muss
also armin laschet hat die grünen schon
eingepreist und ist auch deshalb
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so klare kante
mäßig unterwegs söder sagt wir müssen ja
erst mal unsere eigenen punkte machen
und dann sollen in den
koalitionsverhandlungen die anderen ihre
machen und dann sehen wir mal das ist
ein ganz unterschiedliche
herangehensweise und jetzt wird aus
meiner sicht interessant laschet
verfolgt hier einen makel taktik kurs
nämlich
heißt das argument des anderen schon mal
mit ein und verbessert damit schon von
anfang an seine eigene position während
söder er einen klassischen taktischen
politikstil an den tag legt das ist
meine agenda und jetzt könnt ihr eure
sagen und vielleicht kriegen was dann
irgendwie kompatibel also
zusammengebracht und das problem von
armin laschet zu dem was du gesagt hast
klaus ist ganz eindeutig olaf scholz ist
die deutlich bessere angela merkel
offenbar für sehr viele deutsche als
armin laschet
ihr habt ja viele auch über fußball
gesprochen
tatsächlich ist ja die situation
eigentlich die man liegt irgendwie 0 24
zurück es sind nur noch zwei minuten zu
spielen und man würde in dieser
situation den torwart nach vorne holen
das ist der torwart den wird er gerade
gesehen haben aber er darf nicht nach
vorn das ist der torwart aber um da
vielleicht im bild zu bleiben bei null
zu vier hat es auch sehr schwer denn
selbst wenn dann noch ein rein köpft die
zimmer noch 14
und markus söder hat ja auch gesagt ja
wir sind beide fußballfans er übrigens
vom fanklub genau wie du das stimmt uns
und ich vom mars vorbei des
zweitligaklubs wir haben darüber
gesprochen dass es diesen mythos gibt in
der zweiten liga neuanfang erneuern in
der zweiten liga und dann mit einer
jungen schlagkräftigen truppe wieder
angreifen dieser mythos ist im fußball
genau wie in der politik kompletter
quatsch und das weiß markus söder
natürlich ganz genau wenn die cdu jetzt
das kanzleramt verliert und in dieser
umfrage in diese wahlergebnis dimension
absteigt und damit wird er tatsächlich
in der zweiten liga 19 sind nicht
volkspartei 19 prozent sind halt die
grünen die fdp hat mal das projekt 18 19
prozent die volkspartei wenn die cdu
dahin absteigt dann wird sie da lange
bleiben genauso lange und schmerzlich
wie die spd das durchleben musste die
jetzt gerade nicht wegen urlaubs holz
sondern wegen armin laschet diesen
sagenhaften aufstieg erlebt wir haben
jetzt auch gesehen du hast ihn mehrfach
gefragt wie direkt auch durch die blume
würde er es machen steht er noch hinter
armin laschet was ist denn eure meinung
ich finde man muss wo man so ein
bisschen zwischen den zeilen auch gestik
und mimik schauen wie hat er eurer
meinung nach da performt nimmt man ihm
das wirklich ab dass er zu 100 prozent
hinter armin laschet steht oder konntet
ihr da zwischen den zeilen irgendwas
erkennen ich ja ich habe ja sozusagen
einen in 30 jahren gestellten markus
söder radar ausgeprägt was er sagt was
er vielleicht wirklich damit meint
solange sehe ich den man schon aus
nächster nähe aus verschiedenen
journalistischen positionierungen und
immer wenn er nicht ganz bei dem es was
er sagt fängt er an fränkisch zu
sprechen und soll dem das airbag und er
vergisst die harten tees und so und es
gab heute einige passagen wurde so war
da würde dann das wirkt dann sehr
volkstümlich in wahrheit ist das
sozusagen das erkennungszeichen jetzt
sage ich etwas was ich nicht wirklich
glaube und natürlich glaubt er dass er
der bessere wäre und natürlich glaubt er
wenn er jetzt eingewechselt würde würde
es für die cdu union ein pluspunkt sein
und natürlich würde es gern machen und
natürlich gibt es eine möglichkeit aber
ich glaube es gibt nur eine einzige
möglichkeit und die verlangt armin
laschet vielleicht etwas über
menschliches ab denn eigentlich kann nur
armin laschet diese weiche stellen armin
laschet muss sagen ich bin wir haben
schon fast vergessen cdu-vorsitzender
und der cdu vorsitzender des
vorschlagsrecht für den
kanzlerkandidaten und mein appell wäre
wäre ich jetzt ein unions berater aber
es ist jetzt fast schon mitleid
getrieben meine volkspartei sich so
selber zerlegen und pulverisieren zu
sehen mein rat wäre dass armin laschet
sich darauf besinnt dass er das
vorschlagsrecht hat und er könnte ja
formulieren ich habe das vertrauen der
partei gehabt wir haben jetzt wahlkampf
gemacht wir haben es alle angestrengt
ihr habt euch toll reingehauen ich
selber habe mich rein gehauen im
frühstücksfernsehen habe ich gesehen
dass er schon darüber nachdenken wann
endlich der furchtbare stress vorbei
jetzt mit gibt mit dem wahlkampf und wir
sehen aber unsere chancen wären größer
mit einem anderen kandidaten und deshalb
weiche nürnberg und wir haben das
besprochen markus söder und ich und er
geht am sonntag ins trier es war eine
große große große geste das wäre
wahrscheinlich historisch für die union
bedeutsamer als wenn er ins kanzleramt
einziehen will und daran scheitert dass
wir eine schnelle entscheidung eine am
sonntag in trier wer
jetzt es gibt die szene es gibt die
szene habe ich gerade habe ich gerade
gelesen als wir markus söder gefragt
haben und ich mag es oder gefragt habe
wird der nächste kanzler armin laschet
heißen und man kann sie sich eigentlich
nicht oft genug angucken weil man so
viel in den geschichtlichen gerade sehr
interessant aber
nochmal stichwort auswechseln der marke
soda hat ja selber darauf hingewiesen
dass die briefwahl schon begonnen hat
nun wählen wenn ich die kandidaten
sondern wir wählen die parteien ganz
klar aber trotzdem besser haben wir
spitzenkandidaten hat man natürlich das
im hinterkopf die frage ist ist das
würde das überhaupt möglich sein dass
jetzt noch zu machen als es ist
rechtlich möglich ist juristisch
zulässig es ist ein bisschen
ungewöhnlich aber
er sagte nichts dazu die plakate sind
geklebt wer durch deutschland fährt der
sieht da sind gar keine armin laschet
plakaten ist übrigens die geschichte
dass an vielen standorten diese plakate
zu spät angemeldet worden sind ich
vergessen
in nordrhein westfalen und bin da lagen
die heimat von armin laschet man sieht
ganz viele sind immer ganz viel olaf
scholz man die ganz wenige armin laschet
also und martin hat in dieser weise noch
deprimierender ist aber wahrscheinlich
ist man selber schon mit dem blick jetzt
unterwegs man sieht ganz viele
straßenzüge mit vielen plakaten
hintereinander wo armin laschet klein
und riesig der hinter dieser dieser olaf
scholz der wie ein wie eine gottheit
sozusagen den übrigen die wand an allein
diese bildhaftigkeit ist auch kein
kompliment für den die wahlkampf
ausführer auf der straße die union jetzt
haben wir die entscheidenden sechs sie
und die wir uns anschauen das ende des
interviews
mit markus söder wir schon
der nächste bundeskanzler heißt armin
laschet
klar
man hat auch so ein bisschen das
noch mal und noch mal das ist zu gut
dass muss jetzt aber
man hat so das gefühl er überlegt
eigentlich kurz und der schiebt es
wahrscheinlich auf die auf die
verbindung nach münchen also gehörigen
ronaldo selbst wenn man die sekunde
abzuwickeln brauchst du bist du wir
können das noch mal anschauen wir
schauen jetzt ja
der nächste bundeskanzler heißt armin
laschet
klar
das ist das deutlichste nein in einem
keller des landes gehört nein mir geht
klar sagen ich sag's mal in zwei monaten
klar aber vielleicht haben ja sonst noch
einmal in das ist hoffentlich vielleicht
das bild dieses wahlkampf endspurts für
die union
also das muss richtig ackern kanzler
heißt armin laschet
klar
also deutlicher kann man ironie im
gesicht nicht sein
ja das ist das ist ein tatsächlich ein
moment der wahrheit glaube ich für die
union und wir können jetzt darüber
lachen aber tatsächlich geht es da ja um
sehr sehr viel es geht tatsächlich darum
wird deutschland in den nächsten vier
jahren regiert und ich ja würde mal
sagen das ist fast so etwas wie ein
letzter hilferuf an eine letzte
aufforderung an die partei denjenigen
von dem man weiß er würde mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit sogar gewinnen das
ist ja eigentlich das irre an dieser
geschichte markus söder gegen olaf
scholz steht in den umfragen ja nicht 20
20 21 22
22 22 sondern in den umfragen liegt
markus oder ganz ganz glasklar vor olaf
scholz während armin laschet ganz ganz
glasklar einstellig inzwischen mit 9
zustimmungswerten einstelliger
zustimmungswert von unions
kanzlerkandidat das ist ja eigentlich
das irre an dieser geschichte und ich
glaube das ist fast so was wie eine sich
selbst befohlen die todesspirale dass
union stammpublikum sagt
ihr nehmt denjenigen von dem wir euch
noch in umfragen klar gesagt haben dass
wir den eigentlich gar nicht wollen und
dafür wollen wir es jetzt noch weniger
und dadurch schnee schmelzen diese diese
umfragewerte wie sonst nur die
eisschollen die wir im moment in der
klimadebatte immer unter den eisbären
sehen nicht schmilzt im moment schneller
als diese persönlichen und wir wollen
noch mal ganz kurz reingucken für alle
die es eben verpasst haben hier nochmal
ein best-of markus söder im interview
mit julian reichelt
es gibt jetzt tatsächlich für die union
um alles diese werte die jetzt da sind
sind hoch alarmierend und aber ein
impuls nicht aufzugeben sondern erst
recht zu kämpfen kann die union
überhaupt noch gewinnen
ja wir müssen also wir müssen dieses
ding noch drehen wir müssen den trend
brechen entscheidend ist dass wir vor
der spd landen das muss das ziel sein
das war ein kurzes besten reichen wir
natürlich gleich noch ein paar
interessante bilder von laschet daneben
natürlich wo man ein resigniertes und
irgendwie wie halte ich mich noch mehr
das einzige was man sozusagen ins feld
führen muss mit dem man sich
auseinandersetzen muss das einzige
argument was für das festhalten an armin
laschet spricht ist dass seine partei
nicht im schlussspurt noch das pferd
wechseln kann weil sie sich selber
sozusagen untreu wird in diesem fall ist
aber die ruhige hand die man da
sozusagen dokumentieren will die ruhige
hand die den durchführt den man sich
selber ins herz gerammt und deshalb muss
hier jetzt sozusagen
vielleicht nur meine letzte eine letzte
chance des umdenkens sein sonst landet
die cdu womöglich bei 20 21 einem
historischen tiefstwert ich will auch
nur mal ganz kurz eine kleine lanze für
armin laschet ehebrechen wir sehen
natürlich immer er markus söder fit und
frisch in bayern sitzen unternehmen dann
die bilder des ausgelobten armin laschet
nein er hat ja auch den ganzen wahlkampf
jetzt auch schon hinter sich er ist da
natürlich jeden tag unterwegs ist es ist
man das ist dass ihm das schon genau
sagen da ist natürlich er hat den ganzen
wahlkampf in den knochen aber auch da
muss man sagen es ist bisher nicht
besonders viel wahlkampf den armin
laschet macht ja armin laschet ist nicht
auf den marktplätzen armin laschet ist
nicht in bochum auf der straße armin
laschet war im ganzen süden unseres
landes noch überhaupt nicht da muss man
einmal zugute halten er wollte in den
süden dann kam die flut aber hat den
süden unseres landes bisher so gut wie
gar nicht dass er bereits das was uns so
unbeliebt macht bei den wählerinnen und
wähler naja es ist vielleicht schwerin
besser zu finden wenn man ihn nie sieht
ja armin laschet führt einen wahlkampf
ohne ohne präsenz in der fläche ohne die
hochgekrempelten ärmeln ohne die die
vollen parkplätze ohne das was in den
usa kissing babys heißt er möchte jetzt
vielleicht auch nicht jeder aber aber es
braucht natürlich diesen die dass die
anmutung von schlussspurt wenn man mit
solchen verhält oder muss dazu sagen es
geht ja es geht um einen job der heißt
kanzler
wenn wir daran denken wie wenig frau
merkel geschlafen hat und wie viel sie
unterwegs war also wenn man im wahlkampf
dann erschöpft ist dann kann man auch
nicht ganz klar und ich glaube dass
überzeugungskraft eng zusammenhängt mit
selbst begeisterung also in dem moment
wo man auf einen marktplatz geht wo man
auf eine bühne geht wo man in einem
interview geht bleibt einem gar nichts
anders übrig als es aus seiner position
der eigenen selbst überzeugung zu tun
also ich glaube oskar lafontaine hat
einmal gesagt wer nicht von seinen
eigenen ideen begeistert ist kann auch
niemand anderen dafür begeistern das
gilt auch für die person selber wer
nicht von sich selbst begeistert ist
kann auch keine anderen leute für sich
begeistern und ich glaube wenn man so
mit verlaub in die fresse kriegt wie
armin laschet umfragen getue in der
eigenen partei da muss man einmal markus
söder auch mit rein nehmen denn
natürlich auch immer ein bisschen
gestichelt hat aus münchen also wenn man
praktisch wohin man schaut dinge erkennt
die einem die selbst begeisterung
erschweren dann ist es fast eine
übermenschliche anstrengung es so zu
wirken also könnte man das ding
herumreißen das war jetzt die
psychoanalyse daraus folgt aber nicht
dass man dann mit dem man in den
untergang gehen muss sondern man muss
sich überlegen wie man trotzdem noch ins
kanzleramt kommt aber was muss ich jetzt
machen also ich frage mich gibt es
überhaupt noch irgendeine chance dass
erst nochmal rumreißen kann und wie vor
allem da fehlte auch für mich eine
antwort von markus söder wie das
eventuell die antwort von markus söder
ist hier die antwort in die die union
sich jetzt in ihrer gesamtheit gerade
flüchtet warnung vor dem feind warnung
vor dem linken vor der linken gefahr und
warnung vor dem untergang ich persönlich
teile aus tiefster überzeugung die
warnung vor dieser sed nachfolgepartei
die linke ein grauenvoller laden mit
menschen die wirklich vollkommen anderes
land wollen die mit dem deutschland was
wir haben glücklicherweise die damit
nichts zu tun haben dieses mit ihren
vorgänger schon mal mit einem anderen
deutschland versucht haben das es
fulminant gescheitert deswegen kann ich
die warnung davor sogar verstehen aber
warnung ist keine vision warnung ist
keine perspektive dafür dass jemand sagt
wenn du mich nicht wer jetzt kriegen
jetzt kriegst du aber die damit
entfesselt ich nichts mehr damit
mobilisiere ich nichts mehr und das ist
der ganze entscheidende punkt es gibt
bei wahlkämpfen für unsere zuschauer
kurz erklärt zwei punkte mobilisierung
und aktivierung ich muss die eigenen
leute erstmal mobilisieren und dann über
die eigenen leute hinaus noch weiter
aktivieren menschen die vielleicht
bisher noch nicht in dem fall union
gewählt haben selbst die mobilisierung
der eigenen leute des kernklientel
die menschen die älter sind in diesem
land in all den gruppen in denen die cdu
sein starkes liegen sie hinter der spd
sie kriegen derzeit nicht mal mehr das
eigene das stammpublikum mobilisiert und
die mobilisierung wird mit der roten
socken kampagne nicht mehr funktioniert
wisst ihr was ich dazu sage klar
bis heute ist klar
dass noch mal ran wird in die werbung
gehen und alles klar
klar
ja das war eine brücke sprechen
[Musik]